tout le monde imaginaire plus rien ne
fonctionnerait tout le monde se disait
que l'Allemagne n'aurait plus de charbon
plus de gaz qu'il y aurait une crise
économique massive qu'il y aurait des
difficultés
à extrêmement difficile et un hiver
apocalyptique
tout cela n'a pas eu lieu c'est la
vérité il y a une autre réalité nous
sommes au chaud c'est le cas partout en
Allemagne nous avons pu
sécuriser notre impressionnement
énergétique avec la mise en place de
nouvelles infrastructures et nous avons
agi agit en permettant à notre pays de
sécuriser ses capacités économiques
toutes en limitant et en compensant avec
plusieurs milliards d'euros les
augmentations
du prix de l'énergie
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement a empêché la crise
économique
nous sommes dans une meilleure situation
que ce qui était prévu par nos instances
d'experts nous avons montré ce la
volonté qui était en nous volonté de
surmonter nos difficultés tout cela a eu
lieu à très court terme nous avons pris
un certain nombre de
mesures à très court terme rallongement
de l'exploitation des centrales
nucléaires charbon remplissage
et remplissage de nos stockages de gaz
et mis en place de nouveaux terminaux
métalliers sur les côtes de la Mer du
Nord tout cela très rapidement c'est un
très tout cela constitue un ensemble de
signes très positifs pour notre pays
[Applaudissements]
de dire que c'est un rythme qui a marqué
l'ensemble du pays il s'agit ici de
façonner notre avenir à grande vitesse
nous sommes dans un moment de lutte
contre la crise qui est toujours
sous-jacente et nous agissons rapidement
pour lutter contre cette crise en
particulier avec les énergies
renouvelables le solaire l'éolien la
transformation
de notre industrie
nous voulons devenir le premier pays
neutre en CO2 au niveau
industriel et cela tout cela cela tout
en gardant notre position de 4 m PIB
mondiales toutes ces mesures ne les
prenons dans cet objectif et dans ce
seul objectif
[Applaudissements]
et nous avons respecté nos citoyens
citoyennes dans la mise en œuvre de ces
mesures
mesdames et messieurs
confronté notre économie c'est
l'épouvantable gare d'agression
impérialiste de la Russie contre
l'Ukraine une guerre épouvantable
de sécurité qui prévalait jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
il ne peut pas être permis que les
frontières soient déplacées par la
violence par la force c'était la volonté
de la Russie et c'est pour cette raison
qui qu'au début de la guerre j'avais
parlé ici devant vous d'un changement
d'époque
[Applaudissements]
une bonne chose quand l'un avec nos
partenaires nous soutenions l'Ukraine au
niveau financier au niveau humanitaire
mais également avec des armes
c'est une fracture fracture de notre
politique d'exportation d'un moment
c'est une rupture et l'Allemagne et la
Grande-Bretagne sont les pays européens
qui soutiennent militairement le plus le
crâne
nous avons déjà pris beaucoup de
décisions et si on compte l'ensemble
l'Allemagne sera toujours devant dans le
soutien militaire à l'Ukraine les armes
de l'Allemagne l'énergie de l'Allemagne
est au sont au premier rang dans le
soutien militaire
à ce pays agressé
de livrer des armes lourdes
des lance-roquettes multiples des
systèmes entières et un blindés guépards
dont nous allons livrer de nouvelles
unités des missiles patriotes que j'ai
décidé avec le gouvernement il a très
récemment autant de mesures qui
permettront aux Ukrainiens de se
défendre
toutes ces mesures ont été prises en
coopération très étroite avec nos alliés
c'est la raison pour laquelle elle
fonctionne sur le terrain et la raison
pour laquelle nous les avons prises en
soi
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce que nous allons continuer
mesdames et messieurs les députés nous
allons livrer des véhicules blindés de
combat d'infanterie avec les Américains
des Bradley pour les Américains et nous
l'Allemagne des mardeur les Français
fourniront des blindés de reconnaissance
vous voyez que la coopération est là la
coordination est là c'est un principe et
il est juste car il y a une guerre sur
le sol européen
et ce non loi des frontières de
l'Allemagne c'est pourquoi dans tout ce
que nous faisons nous devons toujours
être clair nous faisons tout ce qui est
nécessaire et tout ce qui est possible
pour soutenir l'Ukraine tout dans
d'éviter la guerre de dégénérer entre un
conflit de grande échelle entre l'OTAN
et la Russie et ce principe va demeurer
ce principe d'empêchement de l'escalade
va rester au cœur de notre action
il n'y a pas de sécurité mathématique
sur ce point personne
ça peut dire
où sont les bonnes et les mauvaises
décisions sur l'escalade c'est pourquoi
nous avons volontairement travailler de
manière
de manière progressive
le sol principe de prudence qui compte
dans une situation d'un si haut niveau
de dangerosité et ce afin de garantir la
sécurité de l'Europe
et cela vaut également pour la dernière
décision prise par le gouvernement nous
allons
livrer des chars de bataille à l'Ukraine
Charles de bataille du type léopard 2
cette décision est les résultats de
concertation intense avec nos alliés et
partenaires internationaux
je veux souligner le fait que cette
décision est juste
nous nous sommes pas laissés pousser à
cette décision nous avons pris le temps
de la concertation et de la coopération
[Applaudissements]
le temps monsieur
nous voulons mettre en place
nous voulons mettre en place des
escadrons de léopard
ukrainien et en lien avec les autres
pays européens qui vont en livrer cela
aura lieu progressivement l'Allemagne va
livrer des léopards
[Musique]
qui sont actuellement en dotation dans
la bonne dose verte nous allons former
les équipages Ukrainiens qui serviront
dans ces chars nous allons également
fournir une logistique en termes de
munitions et de maintenance nous allons
également permettre à nos partenaires
qui disposent de ce char de bataille de
les livrer mesdames et messieurs c'est
un principe juste c'est une mesure juste
c'est une décision juste ce sont des
armes très efficaces
que nous ne livrons pas seul mais en
coopération avec nos partenaires
permettez-moi de conclure mesdames et
messieurs les députés il y a beaucoup
d'hommes et femmes dans ce pays qui sont
inquiets quand tu as une décision de
cette nature et quant à la quant au
point symbolique de cette décision je
veux m'adresser à ces citoyens et
citoyens maintenant faites-moi confiance
faites confiance à votre gouvernement
nous sommes ici en coopération
internationale ce soutien à l'Ukraine
est possible sans être lié à un risque
d'escalade trop important pour notre
pays c'est ce que nous faisons est-ce
que c'est ce que nous allons continuer à
faire je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]